Let's return to the notebook for transformations.
And let me create a new section here.
Call this linear transformations.
Okay. I'm going to borrow this bit.
Close that.
And I'm gonna go from 10.
to 10
also on the y-axis.
So 0 will be the middle of our plot.
PLT is not defined.
PLT is not defined because I need to run these cells so we run
them all.
Okay.
So when we draw vectors, we're going to draw it.
here in the middle
Okay, let's look at let me draw another. Let me draw a vector to
get started with.
Here we have V sub 1 again from before.
Okay, again, I've created this functions to
abstract them away. So the origin of this
Vector will of course be zero.
So if we set this to zero, that means you're going 0
steps from 0 well
That means you're not going to move anywhere on the x-axis or you
have set it here to four.
And since our origin for the other wax, it's also it's
also zero that means four steps up. Anyway, you
basically you draw a vertical line.
And if I want to draw this Vector, I'm going to go draw.
V1
I need to set obj to the ax
object.
And there's my line.
If you want me to make it taller I can just make it
10.
Make it down to wait.
Okay.
So let me show you some what are an example of some geometric
transformations.
And I have a PDF. I want to
show you.
type saved here
yes, for example, this is an example of going from
up to two-dimensional space to three-dimensional space so that this is
a linear transformation.
Okay, so if you want to project a plane.
It's in a three-dimensional space. You can do that. Obviously this has applications and
computer vision.
And computer vision is a subset of machine learning.
These are the conditions we talked about.
Where is the
The transformation that I this is
the one yes, so here look at this one.
Let me show you.
I'm gonna we're gonna go through some of these let me begin with the dish
for example this year.
This is the sheer transformation.
So for example, if we have in our case, we have a straight line.
Yes. Now, of course a matrix or I
should say a plane.
is
You can imagine it being a moth a multitude
of vectors.
I'll show you in the code of what I mean, but I want to show you how we can
take these transform these geometric transformation matrices.
to modify
The shape of our vectors so we will start with
the vectors later on. We will look at transforming matrices doing exactly what
you're saying here.
like skewing matrices
you know when you use Photoshop if you ever use Photoshop
You know you can skew.
a picture
You know, like if you if you're trying to put you know, someone's head
on the body of an elephant, you know.
This is what you're doing. You're doing Matrix Transformations. Okay,
so let me show you how for example The Matrix tissue. Okay
here stands for the degree to which you want to skew or
you want to apply sheer to the play.
Okay, let's begin with the basics. We will eventually get to that
point later on.